it's 10,000 584 divisible by 8 to know
the answer we divide 10,000 584 by 8 if
we get the remainder as 0 we know that
10,000 584 will be divisible by 8 and if
it is nonzero then it is not divisible
by 8 8 multiplied by 1 is 8 we subtract
8 from 10 to get 2 then we get the next
digit down 5 8 multiplied by 3 is 24 we
subtract to get a 1 here we get it down
to boring we are taking too long to find
out if this number is divisible by 8
there is a way in which we could have
answered this question in 5 seconds yes
don't be surprised in this video we will
look at a few divisibility rules these
rules will help us know if a big number
is divisible by another number and yes
within 5 seconds before we move on to
the shortcuts we need to know something
about the number 0 any number multiplied
by 0 results in a 0 transposing any
number to the other side we can say that
0 divided by any number will result in a
0 what does this tell us it tells us
that the number 0 is divisible by any
nonzero number now let's move on to a
few divisibility rules first let's look
at divisibility by 2 how can you tell if
a number is divisible by 2 without
performing any division here's the
simple rule well a number is divisible
by 2 if the last digit that is the
unit's digit of that number is divisible
by 2 what does that mean let's look at a
couple of examples to see how easy it is
to find out if the number is divisible
by 2 here's your first number 980 2356
is this number divisible by 2 to answer
this quickly we just need to look at the
last digit
the last digit is six and since six is
divisible by two the entire number is
divisible by two nine hundred and eighty
two thousand three hundred and fifty six
is divisible by two here's the second
number ten million nine hundred and
eighty seven thousand six hundred and
fifty nine is this number divisible by
two pause the video and try it out is
this number divisible by two the unit's
digit of this number is nine is nine
divisible by two no and that is why this
number is also not divisible by two
that's how simple it gets with
divisibility rules imagine how much time
it would have taken you to manually
divide these two numbers by two and see
if the remainders are zero or not now
let's move on to the second rule
divisibility by four how can we quickly
tell if a number is divisible by four it
is pretty similar to the divisibility
test of two a number is divisible by
four if the number formed by the last
two digits is divisible by four in this
case it is the last two digits in the
case of divisibility test of two we just
had to look at the last digit so is one
million nine hundred and eighty seven
thousand six hundred and thirty two
divisible by four as its divisibility by
four we need to look at the last two
digits the number formed by the last two
digits is 32 is 32 divisible by four yes
so this big number is also divisible by
four here's the next one is 97 billion
four hundred and thirty two thousand one
hundred divisible by four what are the
last two digits here zero and zero the
number formed by the last two digits is
zero and we learnt that zero is
divisible by any number hence this
number is also divisible by four and now
we come to the
divisibility rule of this session
divisibility by eight a number is
divisible by 8 if the numbers formed by
the last three digits is divisible by 8
yes numbers formed by the last three
digits look at the number 16 million
nine hundred ninety eight thousand and
forty eight is it divisible by 8 the
last three digits are 0 for 8 the number
formed by the last three digits is 48
and 48 is divisible by 8 so this huge
number will also be divisible by 8 1 the
rules simple for a number to be exactly
divisible by 2 its last digit should be
divisible by 2 to be exactly divisible
by 4 the number formed by the last two
digits should be divisible by 4 and to
be exactly divisible by 8 the number
formed by the last three digits should
be divisible by 8 we will cover a few
more divisibility rules in the next
session
you